il faut que je vous parle d'un truc je
teste ce castelas qui vient de la marque
française qui s'appelle focale le cast
c'est le célia c'est juste une bombe
atomique à lens je sais je sais je sais
ça va poser de problème à beaucoup de
monde
le prix de ce produit mais franchement
c'est produit complètement ouf estime
encore diouf estime je confirme ce
produit est vraiment au dessus de tout
ce que j'ai pu tester en casque ce que
vous proposez
je vous le présente je vous explique et
vous allez voir le truc et
[Musique]
les casques il en a à tous les prix y en
a tous les prix y en a pour toutes les
bourses et pour tous les marchés et ça
me paraît assez normal et ça paraît du
coup aussi normal que vous trouviez des
casques à moins de 100 euros pour les
plus petits budgets et ça paraît aussi a
contrario normal qu'on puisse trouver
des castes très chère très exigeant pour
les personnes qui n'ont plus les moyens
ou qui veulent en tout cas il met
beaucoup d'argent investi beaucoup
d'argent dans l'o2 parce qu'ils aillent
ça parce qu'ils sont audiophiles si vous
êtes de file est là clairement vous avez
aujourd'hui un des musts un des must
c'est pour moi en tout cas le meilleur
casque que j'ai jamais écouter de toute
ma vie et je dis ça vraiment en pesant
mes mots et j'en écoute et des casques
avant même de faire youtube il ya très
longtemps je trahis dans le fond j'étais
assistant studio fut une époque et j'ai
écouté pas mal de choses et ce truc là
croyez-moi c'est ouf alors c'est pas du
tout outil professionnel salle outils
pour le grand public le grand public tu
cherches un produit vraiment exigeant et
là ça c'est plus d'un casque avant toute
chose regardez moi ça ça c'est juste le
packaging de base dans lequel vous avez
votre caste danse à yassa il ya tout ça
j'ai voulu montrer mais surtout il ya
salle ce truc là c'est ouf
vous êtes sûr sur du cuir le cuir a
priori pleine fleur tout cas c'est un
cuir de vachette qui est juste ouf
et vous le retrouvez tous les côtés là
vraiment définition hyper très bien sur
ce produit
c'est vraiment un choix extrêmement
extrêmement kelly qui est fait par la
marque info call qui est une marque
française stéphanoise sait vraiment où
le boulot est fait alors quand vous
l'ouvrez à l'intérieur vous avez trouvé
deux choses vous allez trouver ça alors
ça c'est pas du tout compris avec le
laissez-passer pour l'écouter vous avez
donc votre casque à l'intérieur et vous
avez cette partie alors dans cette
partie avait retrouvé le câblage vdi
retrouver un petit étui avec plein
d'infos à l'intérieur plein d'infos sur
le casque pour ça c'est vachement cool
surtout en terme de connectique c'est
assez incroyable sur votre case vous
avez deux connectiques là vous avez de
jack mono jacques monod ici left right
il indiquait aussi sur le casque est
bien sûr de l'autre côté vous allez vous
retrouver avec une connectique stéréo
jusque-là tout paraît plutôt normal
malgré deux fois ce que le travail en
terme de finition l'épaisseur du câble
c'est juste incroyable
et ce qui est vachement bien c'est que
dans la boîte vers trouve toujours même
système de jack monopole dans le branché
à votre caste et là vous avez de
l'excellent r 4 points vous allez pas le
brancher sur n'importe quoi mais on voit
tout les xix
jean ce qui est fait là dessus par
focale la recherche de qualité pour ce
produit est tout simplement exceptionnel
pour les hommes sur un produit qui est
destiné aux particuliers aux nomades et
aussi aux personnes qui va écouter de
l'eau de qualité au casque chez eux
pour moi c'est plutôt qu'à ce que vous
allez garder chez vous parce que ce
petit castelet quand je dis petit je la
dérange guy mais ce gros casque là il
coûte quand même 3000 euros alors vous
faites ce que vous voulez votre argent
vous vous baladez un casque à 3000 euros
si vous voulez sur la tête je suis pas
sûr que tout le monde puisse identifier
que c'est un casque à 3000 euros
mais personnellement j'ai toujours un
petit peu peur à mal des avec un casque
de telles valeurs sur les oreilles c'est
ouf officines et à côté de ça je trouve
que l'étui même s'il est très beau très
classe et un petit peu grand pas facile
à mettre dans un sac dans un sac à dos
ou promener comme ça à la main voilà
c'est un petit peu un petit peu la
limite du produit il ya vraiment une
très très belle finition alors c'est pas
ça qui va rendre le produit complètement
dingue mais tout le reste avec le le
cuir pleine fleur sétif et vous le
retrouvez également sur votre cas cela
vous retrouver c'est pareil avec du cuir
pleine fleur là vous avez toute une
partie à l'airé passe on se rend bien
compte leur braguette tout petit
d'aération qui vont venir effectivement
vous apporter du confort lorsque vous le
tenez tous les coussinets en mousse à
mémoire de forme ici qu il vienne
vraiment épouser la forme de votre
oreille vous apporter du confort et de
la légèreté c'est pas un casque qui est
très très lourd on a vraiment une
sensation de légèreté lorsqu on le pose
sur sa tête il ya surtout une très très
belle finition d'un point de vue
purement esthétique un choix qui étaient
parfois 4 qui est vraiment magnifique
fabriqué avec des matériaux complètement
ou fournier sur une finition cognac moka
en plus du fait d'abord ses cousines et
la mousse à mémoire de forme ça vous
donne une bonne isolation passive ce qui
fait que lorsque vous avez sur la tête
eh bien vous n'allez pas avoir le fonds
extérieurs qui arrive parce qu'en fait
le boulot qui fait sur ce cast sang
blood acousticien alors là je vous ai
pas mis les cadres juste pour rire vous
le montrer comme ça ne serait ce qu'en
terme de d'isolation pas si vous savez
il ya beaucoup de casque avec de
l'isolation actifs c'est à dire une
réduction bruit numérique
c'est un petit micro qui va capter le
son ambiant qui va venir l'annuler bon
c'est bien mais des fonds par certaines
pertes aux jo au niveau des fréquences
le fait d'avoir ce travail qui fait d'un
peu du purement acoustique avec des
matériaux choisis qui vont venir fille
très naturellement leçon va faire que
vous n'allez pas voir de déperdition au
niveau de la qualité du rendu
directement pronovost par leur bon ça
c'est vachement bien et lorsque vous le
mettez comme ça on isole déjà j'ai
l'impression si vous venez d'avoir un
casque à isolation active alors on isole
pas autant que si vous aviez par exemple
en wmx n 3 de sony veulent pas de la
même
r mais l'isolation comme ça elle est
déjà super bien et je vous dis une fois
de plus je pense vous êtes plus sur un
casque domestique vous allez écouter de
la musique chez vous dans des conditions
qui sont maîtrisés si vous mettez dans
un avion ça va être bien mais vous aura
quand même une certaine nuisances
extérieures
ça ça me paraît quand même assez normal
le confort au niveau de l'audio j'ai
vraiment l'impression de bon je sens le
casse mais je sens rien de lourd jeu
sans aucun moment un poids sur la tête
et une bonne répartition niveau de
l'arceau au niveau des oreilles c'est
pareil il ya un super confort et ne
serait-ce que saint léger en termes de
confort en termes de travail c'est
vraiment assez hallucinant on va parler
un peu technique très très très très
rapidement pour pouvoir comprendre
comment ils fabriquaient ce produit et
vous des haut parleurs vous avez un dom
m qui est fabriqué en béryllium le
béryllium vous ne trouvez pas globale
dans dans tous les cas ce qu du marché
vous avez également une bobine en cuivre
et la mousse ev ac est positionné
derrière les haut parleurs rien dans la
partie qui se situe ici pour revenir
vraiment filtré leçons et éviter que le
fonds extérieurs viennent vous en outils
dont vous avez une filtration qui est
fait par l'arrière une filtration au
niveau des coussinets c'est quelque
chose qui est complètement maîtrisé et
qui vient vraiment vous isolez
passivement et le rendu est juste
hallucinant
en fait vous avez une sensation de de
précision à tout moment ce qui est
dingue c'est qu'avec ce casque vous
pouvez écouter de la musique à fort
volume ce que je vous déconseille sur
une longue période la foule mais très
faible et bien vous allez avoir
sensiblement la même qualité vous allez
par de déperdition de qualité à faible
volume ya un gros travail qui a été fait
là dessus par l'équipe de focale et le
rendu est vraiment exceptionnel je vous
donne un exemple par exemple j'écoutais
beaucoup de morceaux j'écoutais entre
autres un vieux morceau les connaissent
c'est notre force à nancy five et j'ai
re découvrir je vous jure que c'est vrai
j'ai redécouvert les arrangements je
connais ce morceau je pense que vous le
connaissez déjà vous l'écoutez voilà
vous avez les guitares sûreté c'est très
beau très folk et écoutez j'ai découvert
des parties de piano qui arrivent et qui
disparaissait et surtout ce qui est
assez incroyable excès castres c'est le
rendu d'un prévu spatialisation parce
que j'ai un casque plutôt pas mal qui
est grand public positionné haut de
gamme
c'est le souvenir de me lever à
chenilles l'ex n 3 mais ça croyez moi on
joue pas du tout dans la même commune de
très très très très très loin et c'est
pas qu'une question par rapport aux prix
parce que quand vous le mettez vous
écouter la musique vous avez déjà tout
les reverb sont naturellement positionné
tous les instruments sont positionnés
dans l'espace et ce qui fait que vous
arrivez à capter des choses que vous ne
captez pas
pas capté avec un autre casque vous avez
de la précision par exemple pression des
guitares j'entendais un moment les
bruits de frottement au niveau des
cordes ça paraît pas gênant parce que
c'est normal dans le sou rendu tel qu'il
a été mixé au studio mais vous le
retrouver et au final vous redécouvrez
des choses et vous vous réapproprier la
musique différemment donc je travail qui
est fait en tableaux spatialisation vous
retrouvez les réserves avec un chantier
extrêmement naturelle les sons naturels
des instruments le fait de voir
redécouvrir des arrangements tels qu'ils
sont réellement c'est quelque chose que
vous ne pouvez pas trouver en tout cas
avec un casque si vous n'arrivez pas
dans cette typologie de produits là si
vous écoutez du live si vous écoutez un
concert ça prend toute sa mesure puisque
vous allez vraiment capter le public
beaucoup mieux que vous ne pouvez pas le
cas avec un autre casque il ya une
précision qui élaguent une
spatialisation ya un spectre qui est
extrêmement large et ce quel que soit le
volume que vous allez lui m c'est juste
un travail exceptionnel greffer
là-dessus c'est un produit puisque des
pouvoir utiliser avec tout ce que vous
voulez aussi bien avec un smartphone
qu'avec un baladeur avec ce que vous
voulez avec lynch n en faites ce que
vous voulez il encaissera your
absolument aucun problème
finition confort maroquinerie
spatialisation qualité audio tout est
exceptionnel vous êtes sur un produit
d'exception un produit dont le prix est
justifié les 3000 euros et sont là il
faut savoir derrière vous avez
énormément de recherche et développement
pour réussir à créer ça pour réussi à
créer cet effet de spatialisation pour
réussir à voir cette précision audio
pour avoir ce son qui extrêmement
équilibrée extrêmement naturel
extrêmement qualitatif
le choix des matériaux aussi n'est pas
anodin là forcément gonflé prix vous
avez un casque qui est juste magnifique
et croyez moi si c'est un produit qui
vous intéresse si vous avez le
portefeuille pour pouvoir vous le payez
et bien sûr un usage chez vous vous ne
le regretterez absolument pas après vous
pouvez prendre des relais dans la rue
mais vous balader avec la qualité
restera là il y aura absolument aucun
problème c'est moi c'était un petit peu
peur de me balader avec ce casque focale
la 3000 euros sur les oreilles c'était
un petit peu le truc mais je vous jure
le produit est vraiment sensationnel et
il ce plug parfaitement bien
moi j'utilise avec ça c'est juste
incroyable extrêmement facile vous le
plug et les connectiques sont juste un
magnifique et je suis pas en train de
lancer en me disant un jeu de lens on
sait pour leur sens et je vous assure
que j'adore écouter de la musique
j'écoute beaucoup
coup beaucoup beaucoup au casque que ce
soit chez moi ou en déplacement dans
l'avion n'importe où che coûte
énormément casque et avec ce produit là
avec le style i had focal j'ai vraiment
redécouvert pas mal de choses j'ai
redécouvert des morceaux et c'est pas un
casse qui va être trop flatteur sur
certains points qui va pas vous c'est
sûr mais du grave comme pouvoir sur des
casques beats que je déteste ça c'est
quelque chose d'extrêmement naturel
c'est un casque pour les amoureux de
l'audio pour les amoureux de
l'acoustique pour les audiophiles tout
simplement donc si vous avez trois mille
euros en poche et vous voulez vous faire
plaisir ça c'est juste exceptionnel à
vous dire ce que vous en pensez en bas
en commentaire est ce que vous
connaissez la marque focal qu'est ce que
vous pensez de ce casque est ce qui
pourrait vous tentez ce que vous l'avez
déjà essayé ou alors pourquoi pas est ce
que vous l'avez déjà acheté vous marquez
tout ça en bas en commentaire quant à
moi je retourne me fait plaisir parce
que là que prendre une petite session
qui va me faire du bien vous embrasse
plus tard ciao